dopo salve a tutti
se andava di ragazzi su steve fight
perché miss mi ha preso bene ultimamente
di giocarci perché ogni volta ci gioco
mi diverto un sacco qui volevo fare
almeno altri due episodi giusto gioco
almeno teoricamente io poi ho notato nel
secondo me potrebbero visto gioco
probabilmente per uscire dei dlc
pazzeschi che farebbero un sacco so che
sono pigri come lo schifo però aveva
niente dato fortunatamente gioco
abbastanza vario non laga mai tutto bene
quindi tutto a posto e che si è godibile
tutto godibile senza problemi
ci siamo connessi da qualche parte ma
veramente a proprio si stanno già
allenando la madonna che mappa è hanno
aggiunto le mappe nuove non la conosco
queste chi sono io
eccomi sono blu pinocchio attenzione ma
sono mappe bellissime ma l'uovo non raga
come ho detto prima dove raggiunge i dlc
ecco come ho detto se non l'ho mai fatte
ma sono nuove da pochissimo perché non
le conosco proprio madonna il blu ma ha
fatto il pelo che cadono regali ti da
un'arma random cos'è si fidano delle
armi landon bellissimo bellissima idea
cos'è sta roba un fucile buongiorno ma
come e se hai fatto di più
madonna è rifatto di piombo si non certo
sparato otto volte non è facile però
bellissima sta roba tutto nuovo
attenzione dollari sopra quel tipo super
meat boy a chi arriva prima prima che
c'è un regalo aiuto terzo addirittura
che schifo se riuscite ad aprire il muro
e mezzo
beh io prendo questo mi va bene uguale o
di sotto sequestro i sottosegretari
sotto casa in quella roba lì vai morto
non so cosa sia la prendo io ma
veramente io volevo provare quella e non
sono riuscito a provarla ma come come
com'è possibile
come è possibile si chiamavano aperto
pure perché si guarda come sommesso ma
come ha vinto lui ma lanciato ma come
come possibile ma lanciato lancia puoi
lanciare la lancia ok nora e incredibile
ma veramente ovvero io volevo provare
quell'arma quindi ho scaricato tutta la
mia arma stato messo anche benissimo
grazie
l'ho presa c'è un regalo incastrato
pochi ei che è successo lì a breve
grazie e non si sa più corpi e non fa
niente tanto che muore da allora
innanzitutto rompiamo qua così che deve
venire deve farsi un culo perfetto è
cascato un unico punto dove non ho rotto
lascia che simili non lascia che si meno
sei tranquillo io sono qua tranquillo
bravo a posto
ora devo andare a prendere ciò che è mio
la vittoria no loro prego no l'hayate
male non mi toccare l'ho preso a giovedì
6 prodotto pezzente di qua no no no ma
che cos'è sta roba bellissima voto 7
sono morto era un'arma dmitri
trasportava quando facevi il pendente
sono morto cioccolato fondente ko ma
pistolina perché non la prende e prendi
la mano questo il boss aia non doveva
bilancia il po
sei un pezzente il boss tra da un motore
non lo faceva tu puoi essere un buon
sinistro gioco
ricordate uno fa il boss e gli altri ma
solo io sono sfogato non ho capito non
ero morto io sono sposato aia come
faccio da solo veloce miliardo di cose
io che faccio niente parco demoni era un
casino rifanno al boss del coraggio io
non faccio niente guasto fermo mi prendo
il sole sono tranquillo madonna devo
andare contro i serpenti pure sto gioco
incredibile ora voto sono incazzato semi
cazzati gli alberi che questa no questo
non lo è questo è preferisce vabbè 3 2 1
ieri
ovvio che c'è boss c'è un'arma bianca
cos'è un arma bianca no niente con
esigenze sfondata un'arma madonna rega
donna che volte occhio che ci a metà
vita ci avete a vita equa e guai a chi è
male sparagli sparagli sparagli spara ma
spara di sparare madonna bravo bravo dai
ce la fai
fate circolare di nuovo particolare
forse quando c'è l'anello e perché
speriamo tutti oppure cambia fase stomp
è sporco dei money difficilissimo
ragazzi dobbiamo c'è veramente difficile
fare fuori boss non vedo armi è vicino
al boss toto faccio io anche per i dio
o vuoi vedere come fammi vedere come sta
roba porco demonio porco che ogni volta
che se non sono il boss mi fanno tutti
guarda che adesso la gente non muore
guarda guarda cos'è cos'è cos'è cos'è
cos'è cos'è cos'è
cosa vi rappresenta un casino comunque
per me ho vinto già io e cioè nel senso
più colpiti dalle tante volte che non
solo vogliamo levate a non morire quindi
va bene così per me ho vinto
poi fa nulla state notando ragazzi
quante volte gli sto colpendo si è
impossibile che non siano già morti
quindi va bene a me se colpisci una
volta muoio ma poi dopo più di 65 volta
ho vinto lo stesso però porca vacca
let's roll pistola li sotto tono di
sopra e vi faccio il culetto anno
spedizioni serpentini no ce l'ho fatta
fallo in dieci ma bellissime una cattura
cava che cos'è la madonna lo spara
zucche bellissimo io mi sono ucciso da
solo da vinto lui non ha fatto niente
avresti sono i livelli per halloween o
chi riconosce il boss sicuro sicuro c'è
bossi una gara chi lo prende prima ma
ora kabul
ecco o no l'ha presa lui l'ha presa lui
sono un occhio madonna che botte che
botte che botte fateci caso quanto io
muoio in fretta rispetto allora c'è
quanto quanto dice ho messo l'uscita del
quanto i del tavolo g m bellissimo
bellissimo bellissimo hai visto quante
volte mi ha colpito tre io l'ho
massacrati prima non morivano sia una
scorsi tutti e due sono duemila visto a
meno a e togli di maggia giallo arca
sono vivo io vivo pensate
kalac e mori madonna kate solo fatto
travolte prenditi cosa spalla serpenti
tanto fa cacare una sopra che c'è una
cappa grazie ha detto qua
sorry but madonna e casinò non morire
era morto già sei volte ho mai sparato
due figure quello non è morto otto
proietti in bocca che devo fà destra che
sono iniziate con le normali peccato mi
sono divertito tantissimo in quelle
righe mio mauri che tutti a ok non
aspettare che prendessi ha visto che
vuole verde
ok c'è robert non è coraggioso e non
muore e non muore e non muore
ok raga le ultime tre lai le ultime tre
che mi dia troppo bene però poi basta
peccato è che mi divertivo il sacco
bellissime le mappe nuove allora questa
è lui devo vincere almeno tutte e tre
una serie di così vedrai veramente
incredibile attenzione poi messa in
mezzo invece a dire in mezzo sicuro
previsto qua perché ho paura ma niente
ma perché ce l'hai con me perché sta
cadendo la vacca sacra
sono vivo ce l'ha fatta due che sta
accadendo la mappa non sono le sia così
ma anche la terza dai vinco anche la
terza perché ce l'hai con me aiuto dove
fa no non c è lui ci credo come po come
morto
manca il verde sagredo io la mappa
madonna
proprio lui la finisce così signori 3 su
3 quando gli impegni si giochi sono
capace comunque solo quando mi impegno
si provvede vi sia piaciuto bellissima
il più bel video di steve fight mai
fatto anche di pericoli quando stavo
zitto lasciando per come tu mi piace
ragazzi e fatemi sapere la data bisogno
di questo gioco ma almeno uno ancora ne
faccio iscriviti al canale schiacciata
la campanellina prima ragione i suoi
video come sempre ci vediamo allora
proseguito ai ragazzi
[Musica]